[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings the fight
over texas new abortion law is just the
latest in a series of battles around roe
v wade for decades after the supreme
court upheld the right to an abortion
the efforts to challenge this
controversial decision well it's been
constant the woman at the center of the
case was known first as jane rowe but
her real name was norma mccorvey she was
a mother of two when she filed a case
and a mother of three by the time it was
decided
jan crawford spoke with mccorvey's
oldest daughter her name is melissa
mills they spoke at her home in texas
this is a candid conversation about a
very complicated history and this is her
first tv interview
not everybody's meant to be a mother and
i didn't expect that of her she was the
mother she could be as a young girl
melissa mills didn't know her mother
norma mccorvey was known to everyone
else as jane rowe a complicated at times
dysfunctional woman melissa was raised
by her maternal grandmother how would
you describe your mother
she was really funny she was the life of
the party
i didn't think of her as a mother figure
i thought of her more like a sister
because that's how our relationship was
melissa was almost a teenager when she
realized her mother was jane roe of roe
versus wade that's when she also learned
she had two younger half sisters
jennifer ferguson and shelley thornton
shelley was the child known as baby ro
journalist joshua prager spoke to the
three women in his upcoming book the
family row an american story proportions
shared with the atlantic i think most
people have no idea that there is a baby
row we were all given up for adoption
but my grandparents adopted me
and the other two were given up at birth
she couldn't take care of herself much
less anybody else the sisters met back
in 2013. we only had like 24 hours
together it was very short and we got as
much in as we could according to
prager's book thornton refused to meet
mccorvey the woman who told the world
she didn't want her shelley never met
her and i think it was just too much
and i understand that um when somebody i
mean she wanted to abort her and she
told shelley that
she expected her to thank her for not
doing so
mom had
mom had a sick sense of humor i mean she
was her humor was pretty harsh and she
was mad at shelley because shelley
wouldn't do a dna test when shelley
wouldn't it kind of you know
kind of made her mad made her mad as the
only daughter who knew mccorvey growing
up mills vowed she would be different
you wanted stability
and civility and family family yep how
are you able to do that
i guess when you want something you do
it
what are you most proud of
my kids
and the way you've been able to be the
kind of mother
that you didn't have right
mccorvey felt she never fit in used by
both sides at some point she
crossed over and
started speaking on the other side right
against abortion rights yeah she felt
guilty and people made her feel bad for
the part and the role that she played
with the roe versus wade case
and all the babies that were aborted
through the years and people would call
her a killer they called her satan they
called her all kinds of terrible things
it was it was cruel mccorvey spent the
last year of her life in texas near
melissa and melissa's two daughters she
died in 2017 leaving behind a legacy
that remains as divisive as ever you
know we all like feel protective of our
moms and they're mentally protected yeah
that's it seems like you i think that's
human nature right like you
even if your mom has flaws that's your
mom
what was that like for you
it was hard
but i didn't want anybody to hurt her
and i felt she was even though she was
strong she was fragile
she was strong but fragile
and you could see that
jan crawford reporting there uh it's a
powerful piece powerful interview the
family row is the name for it how
fitting in a way that the complicated
relationship we all have to abortion as
a country is contained within jane rowe
herself who has been on both sides of
the issue i mean it just goes to show
you there's family drama it seems in all
things i think most people don't even
realize that baby roe was actually born
i know she filed the case and then but
it took so long the baby came so it
became a point i think it's interesting
that shelley when you learn her name is
shelley didn't want to meet her mother
and when you think about what she been
through you're right and then saying you
know when you want something you just do
it do it um i know she grew up
conflicted given everything um that
happened to her as a child but now she's
like you know what i want to be a great
mother to my daughters yeah there's an
endless legacy and that's one of the
better parts of this legacy no doubt
we're going to be talking to the author
of that book by the way on monday who
actually sat down with all three of the
daughters including shelley i think
he'll have a lot to say i think so it's
a very big book
there's a lot to say a reporter and a
great writer and this is a different
kind of book for him so i'm looking
forward to it and jan thank you again
great interview